I know this is a general question. Your pseudonym is Mujeok Pink (which literally translates into Invincible Pink)
Any particular reason or background to adopt your pseudonym?
I didn't plan to use a pseudonym, although it is a quite common practice in the field
I thought Mujeok Pink will give an easy hint to guess which generation I am from
This was a nickname for my blog and I was 7th grade when I first started it
Since I was a big fan of Power Ranger and the Flash, I initiated my nickname with Mujeok (invincible)
Usually it is followed by a color and girls typically go for either yellow or pink
But pink was my to-go color and that is how it ended up with Mujeok Pink
When we were young, we all used to think we are at the center of the world. Like I used to think I need to protect this world and those foolish people
I named my blog as Secret Haven and have been writing with pseudonym Mujeok Pink
It is only that I never knew I would continue to write until the age of 30. It is shameful
Although my real name is Jimin Byun, but I have lived and being introduced as Mujeok Pink
Not a while ago, I visited the National History Compilation Committee
You see..my hair is bleached now, but it was pink when I made a visit
We are talking about the audience consisting of historians dedicated to study Korean history over several decades and I introduced myself as Hello, my name is Mujeok Pink.
Please be cautious to come up with your ID
Mujeok Pink is my identity but I am satisfied with where I am now
You currently publish several series of fun and unique webtoons. Could you briefly introduce your works?
Yes. I publish three series of webtoons at the moment. Two episodes per week
All of them happened to be historic webtoons. Joseon Wangjo Sil Talk (True Stories of the Joseon Dynasty) is available at Naver
Basically I transform historical events in Joseon in messenger format
For example, the king would send messenger gifts to the prime minister not to step down
The World History Talk is a spin-off series and is available at Wisdom House. They publish lots of educational books
It is themed on world history in a messenger format where Napoleon and Cleopatra are in the same group chat
Qin Shi Huang would bury someone and take proof shoot
The last one is The Three Kingdom, which is also developed in a messenger format
I update 6 episodes per week. Put it in this way. You are submitting six final papers every week. I am happy thou
As your subscriber, I am glad you said you are happy. I wonder how you manage your time
First of all, I need time to do my time management, but I don't. So it is either I work or not
In these days, it is more like I work and more works are lining up as if someone is waiting to knock on my door
So I work every day. I work, eat and sleep. My schedule was not this tight when I used to post one webtoon series
I was able to take at least one day off and I would hang out, read or watch movies
As I literally work seven days per week, I even started to lose the sense of weather transitions. The last movie I watched was The Avengers: Age of Ultron
I was not sure if this is a lifestyle that a human being deserves, but you guys work at Google
I am pretty sure you understand what I am talking about life without life in which you are imprisoned at the company. I think they use this term Crunch Mode at gaming companies
I do not think I ever worked to the extent where I feel imprisoned. But we are always exposed to working environments regardless of time and location
Oh you rephrased. Basically you are like a freelancer who does not commute, but you just have this
I can sense a variety of contemporary components in your webtoons
Although your themes are based on events occurred 300 ~ 500 years ago, I thought the way you illustrated was very modern
Do you have any routine to keep your modern senses or any triggering event?
Well..yes. my webtoons are staged 300 ~ 500 years and actually 1800 years in case of The Three Kingdom
I think they are customized towards modern readers to certain extent
It may sound cynical, but I think the essence of human life remains the same. I also have that quote at my work place
It is so true that I do not need to modify the essence
Whether it is King Sejong, Cao Cao or Liu Bei, they are human being after all who share the same sense of emotion with us
They feel various feelings, be jealous on same things, and share the same ambition trigger
The way they confront conflicts is no different either
They reconcile, fight or do tricks to set them apart. I actually learned from the essence of their life
I thought people lived several centuries ago were fundamentally different, but they are actually not. All I need to worry was how to put them together
Then how to convince the readers? I just removed old languages
I removed old languages and built wifi and cell phone in historical settings. I replaced historical words with emoji
With this, my subscribers can sympathize first of all, and realized that human life is same after all, because we all tend to think that there might be something special about great men in history
Earlier you asked how I do my research
My virtual readers..I will call them Netizen. They are very fast paced
I just closed episode 350 for Joseon Wangjo Sil Talk and the tone has been changed just over 100 episodes. It just took one year
Even cell phone models have been changed. In my first episode, the cell phone was small enough to reveal King Sejongs holding fingers
Now that smartphones have become bigger, I only reveal his thumb. I need to purely observe changes in cell phone or display
And language tone is the most important most of all
I am 30 years old and I do not understand the language that 20 year old speaks. Sometime I do not even get what 25 year old speaks
I have to keep utilize big data and do research. I was able to spot all of them at Monopoly online cafe
I think I joined three cafe where young generation get together. I key in the word or phrase in those cafes to see whether they are still in use or not
If there is no record during the past two months, it means they are no longer in use
Then my concern would be finding the new contemporary word that replaced
I start to search for synonyms and there are lots of interesting words. I mainly use Youtube. Do you know Bapung and Ins?
BAPUNG (meaning Wind Balloon) refers to slime that does not stick to hands. When slime is smashed on the desk, it creates bubble
Whoever makes big bubble wins. I learned it from elementary school students
One day, youtubers were invited to an elementary student to talk about job exploration and I was about to brag about the new word BAPUNG that I learned and it was used as if it is a common word
INS refers to printed sticker. You hand over your favorite picture to a printing company to print them into sticker
They will not care about copyright. Anyway I learn these new contemporary words
You might think I would scold people for not using proper language since I like history, but I actively learn new words than anyone because words carry soul
Sometimes I am told that my language is childish. It is a complement
I think it is a complement indeed. Joseon Wangjo Sil Talk is where I learn new slangs from
Thank you
Thanks for being a teacher to all of us
We just talked about webtoon from its content perspective. What are your thoughts on webtoon as a platform that distribute digital contents?
It is an interesting area to discuss and I actually give lot of thoughts on it
It has been a decade since I published my first webtoon
What is the normal rank at a company with 10 years of experiences? Manager? Senior manager?
Anyway, there are people working for you at that point. I thought that it is a time to be more responsible
Previously, I didn't negotiate on fees and accepted whatever works that were requested
Someone with the most experiences in my field advised me that I look like the most junior among the first generation of webtoonists based on my work behavior
I am the first generation no matter what and have the responsibility to pave the way for the next generations
Let me ask you this. If we say webtoon is a building, then Google is engaged in a real estate business in a virtual world.
Actually not..it is a real world because you are paid
Anyway you are in a real estate business. What is the biggest issue?
Who wants to give a great answer?
Current issue. You are a landlord. What are your thoughts? I will give out my answer based on how you word your answer
Anyone from Youtube team?
You..who just had an eye contact with me. We talked earlier at pantry. Could you please share current issue of Google?
Current issue?
Yeah. Something that wakes you up when you think about it
The increase of creators in Youtube translates into the increase in tenant in real estate analogy and I guess our concern is how to drive these creators to produce contents of great quality
Tenants share the same concern. How to create better contents?
There is only one solution MONEY. You need to make a living out of doing what you like
For example, I am a webtoonist and it is great if I make money out of drawing webtoons
I can get a part time job and still make income, but that does not do any good to the ecosystem of my industry
Even if I win a million dollar lottery, the same million dollar earned by drawing webtoon make positive impacts to the industry at a totally different level
In this perspective, full-time webtoonists should make living out of it and I guess that is my major concern
Webtoonist might slightly deviates from Youtubers in this perspective
Reputation used to bring bucks to both Webtoonists and Youtubers because each click brings extra cents
However in these days, reputation does not necessarily guarantee high income because the conversion rate to cash is lowered
I have more than two million subscribers. It is a huge number. What is the population of Gwangju?
What about a district in Seoul? I am LG Twins fan and 45,000 people can fit into Jamsil Stadium
Pretty much 50 stadiums subscribe my contents. But 2 million subscribers do not make me rich
There are probably only a handful of webtoonists who own house in Seoul. Contents that we create does not bear fruits
What is that mean? It does not sustain. There are several reasons
Illegal sharing is the primary reason, which is known to steal 80% of the profitability
Although an illegal sharing platform called Bamtokki was recently suspended, but it did not help too much
I ponder how to cope with where we are situated
Contents that are viewed by multiple people implies that it is well made, which also translates into that the author delivers contemporary messages
Nonetheless, they cannot make a living out of it. My mom has a cancer and I cannot afford to send her to hospital
Do you realize that webtoonists cannot get married unless they have a major hit?
If you are married, you have a series that went viral
If you have kids?? Then you made really big hits
Let us say I have a husband・let me put that back because I will have to give birth then
Let us say my family had a baby and there are choice you have to make along the way
You need pain killer, $100 or $500 nutritional supplements and even if I have 2 million subscribers, I still feel pressured to buy $500 supplements
Why contents does not convert into cash? Why people no longer pay to view contents?
Why does our main source of income come from advertisement?
Advertisement profit is not primary source of income for us
It is merely based on the trust that someone will make purchases after being exposed to this small banner
I dig into historical evidences up to 10,000 years ago to create my contents
I only charge 10 cents per episode so it only cost 80 cents per month. I want to charge them more like up to 2 dollars
Just give me 2 dollars..would you? If you do not have cash, you can pay with credit card
I am confident that I can continue to do this work if every viewer pays two dollars per month
At least I am in a much better position than other peers. I have fans, agency and manager YLAB who takes good care of me
I can afford to consult with lawyers to file lawsuits
However, the majority of creator who practically blow breath to this industry, including both webtoon and youtube, are powerless and speechless
They sacrifice future, time, passion and health for what? I feel they are looking at the middle of darkness
We are not sustainable. What shall we do?
There are lands that need to be explored, but explorers are starving to death
I think this is a serious problem. I bet you clicked a video because the title sounded sensational, but it ended up wasting your time to watch it
Guess what? This will continue as long as compensation issue remains unsolved. People work what they are paid for
You always seem to be bright and vibrant, but I am seeing the other side of you tonight as you shared serious thoughts and reflections on webtoon industry
Speaking of work, I am an employee at Google and I raise the same question to every guest speaker at Talks at Google
Have you ever imagined that someday your job can possibly be replaced by AI? If you agree, which form do you think it will take place?
I thought that simple and repetitive parts of my work could be replaced
For example, re-organizing historical events for easy understanding, whether in forms of messenger or social media, is one
It is simply cleaning historical data and organize them into given formats
Of course, AI has better searching skills and I thought that AI could replace me as long as it is tuned to contemporary words with historical backgrounds
I played a game recently..actually Google made it
I drew picture of the words that AI suggested and it guess what it is
For example, I draw TV and if AI made correct guess, I win. It was quite interesting indeed
I thought AI would learn from human, but it turns out that I was learning the ecosystem of AI
It felt strange because I drew TV and it obviously looked like TV, but AI was telling me it is a box
Then I realized that AI only recognized outlines
Then I started to think from AI perspective to which extent I should simplify my drawing so that AI will recognize what I meant
To describe my works in beverages, it is like adding espresso shots in green tea
It is grotesque. Who would ever thought that, but people do
Whether that was a mistake or not, people think in opposite ways
That is type of the works that I do. Narrating Joseon history in form of a social messenger
and I also created a textbook of virtual reality as a senior project when I was in college
I combine two extremes or something that are not cohesive in any aspect at all. But AI is smart, productive and intelligent.
I think AI will be a good assistant to my projects because I do not think it will make any mistake
I mean..AI beat Lee Sedol (A legendary go player). AI will be fine for next 5 years at least
I am still concerned regardless how quickly AI develops because as I said earlier, it does not make money
AI functions based on repetitive learning. But the trends change from time to time. It used to be martial arts, followed by sexual and gangsters
Once the area of learning is narrowed down, AI can only concentrate on certain things and dig into them
I hear d AI also writes good novel these days
Both our work scope and preference will continue to narrow down, giving AI more limited areas of concentration, then AI will easily catch up
AI already better paint than I do. AI should pay tax. I never imagine AI would beat Lee Sedol at this stage
I thought the event will take place when I am around 70 years old
However the reality is AI already won Lee Sedol, does coloring, write novels and songs and who know what will happen a year later?
Whether it is GiGa Genie or Google Assistant, I want to have them to change channel
Building a bright future with AI sounds pleasant. How do you imagine yourself after one or 10 years?
00:29:30,000 --> 00:27:28,000
I will be drawing webtoons probably. I do not have personal memory since 2016, which means this will continue until 2019
I will be drawing. I hope I will survive
Yes. I wish to keep subscribe your webtoons
Please make sure to buy me virtual coins
Now I will toss it to the audience for Q&A session. Please raise your hand if you would like to ask anything to her
Please feel free to ask personal questions such as what game do you play? Oh I play Candy Crush by the way
Hi I am an engineer at Google
You shared challenges in webtoon industry and, as a matter of fact, software industry went through the same
Copying software program became a normal practice and people were fooled for using software out of their pocket
Anyway, I think there are ways to make improvements along the way
What kind of changes do you think it will make positive impacts in your industry?
The portal where I post World History Talk was established by a publishing company
I was convinced when I heard of Wisdom House launched webtoon business because they have a long history of exchanging scripts with authors
In other words, we went through a dark age where authors were arrested due to censorship, and there were editor who visited imprisoned authors in person with snacks to check on their status
They show courtesy to the authors. So you know you are respected as you talk to them, even though they are rookie
They might experience trial and error in the beginning, but I was convinced that they will be directed towards the right path
As a matter of fact, authors are often offended because they are in close communication with the readers
Wisdom House take actions to protect the authors or send presents during Korean Thanksgiving
Most of all, they giveaway free books since they are publisher
They feed the authors both physically and intellectually and show respect to authors that they deserve
In return, I did my best on my end as well. I didn't feel like being a printer
I am explicitly promoting Justoon
Please subscribe and also monitor them as well because I have witness many publishers that launched a new business with healthy motive, but soon became materialized
They forgot the core business value, which resulted in losing both trust and readers
Webtoon market has a short history with 15 years. However, the rise and fall has been very dynamic and there a lot to learn from it
What I learned is to show professional respect to those I work with that they deserve
This is very fundamental thing to do, yet it is difficult to be consistent. I think even a word era is outdated given the pace of changes we face
A challenge is replaced by another and we will face new challenges overnight
New challenges come with new roles, however, what does not change tasks managed by human
Human is the most important. I recall only three people in my industry who stick to that principle
I have two questions. One is the web ecosystem
It seems that the industry keeps growing, although wealth distribution is another matter
There are new players in the market that plans and creates contents as a middle person like YLAB.
Could you please explain how you cooperate with YLAB?
Also, you seem to do research on tones and languages, but I find that tones from your characters differ from one another
Especially Cao Cao and Yuan Shao from The Three Kingdom have unique tone. Do you have any research object for benchmark?
It is an interesting question
My relationship with YLAB? I am good with them
Our relationship is combination of fandom, loyalty, family and they also help me with money and legal issues
When I say something and it is contractual issue, they would review even though it is against their profit
If copyright or malicious comment issues occur during the review, they would hire a lawyer for me
Because you will see tons of weirdoes from historical webtoons. The genuine history maniacs would be on my side, but those who pretend to be offend me
In addition, there are authors at YLAB and they are my colleague, subscriber, and fan and working with them definitely synergize
It is a desirable business model, but investors will get involved to expand their business later on. I hope they move towards a right direction
Moving on to the next question, I think tone represents your identity
You will notice that people use different tone at group chats
Elders tend to finish the sentence with multiple dots and shorten their sentence as if they can never write more than three lines and etc
I did not pay much attention to it in the beginning, but it turns out that their life is immersed into their tones
Non-verbal expression is critical as well and each one has its model, including a number of King from Joseon and characters from The Three Kingdom
In The Three Kingdom, Yuan Shao is full of non-verbal expressions. He does not initiate any conversation
Most of people believe that the Three Kingdom is represented by Liu Bei, Cao Cao, and the Son family, but I would say 70% of the story deals with different characters
Yuan Shao is from a noble family and he does not initiate conversation
If he has to, he would only start a chat with Cao Cao by just calling his name
In reality, people with high profile would call my name first and remain silent until I answer back
They will call my name multiple time until I finally answer back
For example, if my script needs to be edited, editors usually just ask me to do so
However, high rank officers first summon me before digging into main agenda
Yuan Shao would always call Cao Cao name first before initiating the main conversation
Aman is Cao Cao nick name and he would call Aman repeatedly until he answers
Cao Cao spent the most of his early years with loyalty. He killed those violated the boundary of law, and did not commit habitual killing
He got sick of the law system at his time and sought for power
He was very busy as to lose his humanity, which is immersed in the way he communicate
Cao Cao does not go more than a sentence when he talks to his family and complete his sentence with noun followed by period
My friends studying law are obsessed with putting period to finish sentences
Last question?
I will take two more. The one in red and blue
You mentioned that you upload six episodes per week for three series
You are so busy that you cannot even really remember the last movie you watched. You are committed to you works without personal life
How long does it take for you to draw one episode and which aspect of your work is the most time consuming? Do you have assistants? If so, what is their role?
The majority of my time goes to The Three Kingdoms Talk
I usually spend five days on it and split the other two days on The World History and Joseon Wangjo Sil Talk
I am pretty used to Joseon Wangjo Sil Talk at this stage and it does not take more than a day
I have more know-hows to come up with new episode themes. For example, what is the day today by the way?
Battle of Myeongnyang took place today. Today is Oct 28th right?
25th
Look at me..For example, I used to have the dates of historical events on my cell phone calendar, including the birthday of kings of Joseon, anniversary or the date of death and etc
Joseon Wangjo Sil Talk is updated on every Wednesday and Sunday so it is easier for me choose theme and put them into day-based frame
Also, I have been doing a special episode on Hangul Day for five consecutive years along with Korean New Year and Thanksgiving Day to talk about Korean traditional rites
I also try to address social issues at the time of writing such as college tuition and housing prices etc., which apparently had to be dealt with centuries ago
For example, public officers in Joseon had to let go 90% of their salary for housing to work in Seoul
I do not much struggle to come up with new episode ideas for Joseon Wangjo Sil Talk
Once I know what to write about, then rest of the process does not take that long
The Three Kingdom Talk takes much longer because it is not easy for me to decide which scenes that the subscribers are interested to read
The Three Kingdom is very interesting by itself
The real historical events took place almost 2,000 years ago then the story was novelized nearly 600 years ago and it has been passed down since then
However, The Three Kingdom seem to be very old-fashioned at its first glance as if only those in 50s would read
So I think of ways to make it more accessible to young readers who can sympathize
I changed Chinese ranks into terms that Koreans are more familiar with
For 1 on 1 battle, I replaced it with screen capture or youtube format
For the scene where you make order to the adviser, I used the setting where the adviser is invited to a group chat to receive the order
This is my first level of transformation
The second level of transformation is change in emphasis
To sympathize with the new generation, it should no longer be Liu Fei and Cao Cao that we all know
Martial arts was the key to success 20 years ago. Million copies were guaranteed
However, the same paradigm will not sustain a month in these days because our generation grew up watching the monitor
They do not get used to wide screen or even detailed pictures
As the key viewing channel is shifting from PC to mobile, authors started to spend less time in drawing cuts because even well-made pictures are distorted to certain extent in mobile format
People no longer reads so the length of lines shortened
The Three Kingdom is a soap opera with scale so my main struggle was changing the point of view to the first person perspective
For example, the webtoon begins with Liu Fei who is 23 year-old employed where he ask google whether 23 year-old jobless living in mom's house should kill himself or not
Cao Cao who was a public officer would say something like this damn country should fail as an attempt to change the world
Or I turned Yuan Shao who likes getting attention into a social media celebrity
Describing their desire and ambition in 21st century language is challenging because I do not meet many people to have desires
I just want to sleep. This is my concern. I know I am committed to my work, but I feel isolated from the society
I wonder whether my work brings value. Does 24 hour that I spend help hungry kids in Kenya?
I feel this disparity when I travel
I think building a house for Habitat brings much more value than drawing webtoons, but I have not traveled in recent 5 years
Being honest with my desire is good..not forgetting that I am a human being
Then I think I will be able to find various themes. I have to be humane first to understand how others think
The one in blue
Hi. I am an engineer at Google
Your story was interesting and the way your put them together was fun as well
I thought you could give me advice. How can I become a fun story teller?
You also talked about AI. In AI era, you mentioned that people will seek entertainment over productivity. What categorize entertainment in AI era?
I do not think fun stories are out of creativity. It comes from observation. It is a long process
I have a good educational background just like everyone in this room
It means that you theoretically understand fun. In other words, you cannot do something that makes you look undermined
I made a big hit with Joseon Wangjo Sil Talk as a webtoonist. But I thought myself as a noble, studious and cynical person
I would pursue the truth to become light to this world and looked deep inside, thinking that I would every possible desire in me
I was seen as an author with many subscribers, but our interest is making money to be honest
Money is good
There are things that I want to enjoy by paying money and that is good for me
Maybe I like too much coins but anyways I want to make money and be successful
That is how I get paid for my salary・to protect the server
I need to observe others in more detail to be paid even more. Contemporary people are very unique
Consumer, reader, Netizen are all same group of people, but the way they communicate is very unique
You have to witness with your own eyes. There are several differences that I feel as an author
First, the way of thinking has been changed. They do not get metaphor anymore
In the past, people knew what it meant to be delightful with tears in their eye or being cold to someone when you actually love them inside
This does not work anymore. When someone is angry, they will only believe it when I emphasize that they are angry
They will have to accept it. People do not want me to use rhetoric for explanation
This is very interesting. But we are busy, especially inside of the building
I am captivated inside of well decorated building for my word, but you need to use time to meet people for observation
At the same time meeting people is tiring
I get uncomfortable when I encounter someone having different thoughts, especially when they are younger
I have that resistance in me. Maybe it is because I am stubborn or level of my education
However, I have to invest my time and be patient with them and observe until I understand
When I do not understand their pattern, I need to memorize them at least. This is painful
I used to enjoy using elegant words, but my subscribers are 4th graders
I have to put everything in the view of 4th graders. I actually learned this from one producer
One day, I talked to a producer with milestone programs. Their world is very intense and competitive. You never know when to get fired
Then I asked him for know-how and he said that if you can make a program that 8th grader understands, then the rest of humanity would understand
That happened four years ago and that was very helpful advice.
I only imagined subscribers ranging from 20 to 30 year old. I targeted 8th graders as my potential reader and he said that it has been pushed down to 4th grader. Humanity evolves
You should remember this 4th grader rule. This is not something to laugh about
Everyone in this room should be 4th grader. Do you know how hard it is? Because it comes with a sense of shame
Why did I go to college and paid tuition if I have to put myself into 4th grader's position?
My colleagues say that they wish they are 11th graders. Then they can write milestone episodes
Does it answer your question?
There is an impressive quote from your other interview. You said that you draw historical cartoons, but its essence is ordinary life and human story
I hope you would continue to keep this sharp sense of observation to provide us with great contents
I wish we could present a great gift to you, but only guest speakers at Talk at Google can have this doll